-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show"!
I'm here with Steve Higgins,
and we're about to play
a brand-new game called
"Imposter Challenge."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Imposter Challenge ♪
But first,
we're gonna need some help.
He's a five-time
Grammy-nominated...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...musician, and his music
has been streamed
over 30 billion times.
[ Cheers and applause ]
His new solo album,
"D-DAY," is out now.
Please welcome global pop-music
icon from BTS, Suga!
[ Cheers and applause ]
How you doing?
Good to see you.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Thank you for --
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Thank you for being here.
Uh, Higgins -- Higgins --
Higgins, can you --
Higgins, can you explain how --
[ Cheering continues ]
-Yes, I can, Jimmy!
-Yes.
Explain how the game works.
-Jimmy and Suga will be given
two things to eat
that look identical.
One tastes good...
and the other does not.
-Okay.
They must eat
what they are presented with
while trying to convince
the audience
that they like the taste.
Then the audience will vote
for who they think
ate the gross thing.
There'll be three rounds.
Okay?
-Three rounds. Okay.
-You ready?
-Yeah, I'm ready.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
For the first round,
we have two spoons.
One has salt and one has sugar.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy, you will go first.
-Go first.
-You're --
You're my guest.
All right, so one is salt,
one is sugar.
-Jimmy, whenever you're ready.
-All right. And --
-That's your spoon.
♪♪
Mmmmm!
[ Laughter ]
Suga, it's your turn.
Eat whenever you are ready.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
Okay. Audience?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Audience,
time to cast your votes.
[ Laughter ]
You all have your voting
clickers at your seat.
If you think Jimmy
ate the salt...
-I tried.
-...vote Jimmy.
If you think Suga ate the salt,
vote Suga.
Ready, guys?
Vote away.
I think it's pretty obvious
who had the salt,
but maybe some people
aren't convinced.
I tried to act like...
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Okay.
-Yep.
All right. The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
-Oh, Jimmy.
The audience thinks Jimmy
is the imposter.
Jimmy, let's find out
who actually
ate the salt.
Imposter, reveal yourself.
-He ate the salt.
-I'm the imposter.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow.
-You thought he was acting?
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No, he's just -- He's --
He just took it --
He put his tongue in it
and was like, "Ugh!"
-"I'm not eating that."
-I put a full spoon
of sugar in there.
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
But, wow, I love you guys
for believing me.
All right.
-All right.
-Ready?
Time for round 2.
-Okay.
-The deuce.
Ready?
You're gonna have
two glasses in front of you.
One has vinegar.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
The other has water.
[ Laughter ]
-I know. I don't know.
[ Inhales sharply ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Suga, your turn.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right!
Press Jimmy if you think Jimmy
drank the vinegar.
Press Suga if you think Suga
Who drank the vinegar?
Ready?
Everybody ready?
Okay, the votes are in.
Let's see the results.
The audience thinks Suga
is the imposter.
Okay. Let's find out
who drank the vinegar.
Imposter, reveal yourself.
-I drank the vinegar.
Ugh!
That was disgusting.
That was disgusting, dude!
I'm crying. I'm crying.
[ Laughter ]
That was disgusting!
Oh, my gosh.
-Then you're gonna love
this next one.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Next one?
-It's time for the final round.
For this one,
you each have a chicken wing.
One has no spice --
mmm, tasty.
The other has been doused
in Trinidad Scorpion Hot sauce.
[ Laughter, cheers ]
-I never heard of that.
-Well, it's hotter
than a ghost pepper.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
I think you need
a license to touch it.
Okay.
-But he has to --
He has to perform tonight.
-Well...
-He has to sing.
He has to --
Jimmy, whenever you're ready.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-Okay.
-Okay, Suga. Your turn.
♪♪
[ Cheering ]
Okay.
Gonna count those votes up.
That's scorpion hot pepper.
Votes are in.
Let's see what we got.
They think Jimmy did.
Okay.
Imposter, reveal yourself.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
-No vinegar, no hot.
Well done, audience!
Well done!
Since you did
such a great job guessing,
everyone in the audience
is going home tonight
with a free pint of
Tonight Dough ice cream.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks with Suga!
We'll be talking more to Suga
after the break.
Stick around, everybody!